index notation now I very very briefly
alluded to this when we were talking
about different operations I'm the
integers so the first idea I want you to
remember is about the for normal
operations that you've got okay now for
operations what were they
what was this if this one addition what
comes along with subtraction really
there are two versions of the same thing
okay and then what were the other ones
yep multiplication and along with
multiplication goes excellent okay so
there we are you got your four
operations but the thing is they're not
really for operations are they because
as you noticed they're kind of paired up
right subtraction is just addition in
the other direction
writing the same with division
multiplexing but not only that for
multiplication right it has a
relationship to addition it's not a
totally separate thing does anyone
remember what the relation should be is
Morgan yeah okay I think we've got the
right idea let's write it down to
remember and we'll go with that example
we can say instead of writing 4 plus 4
plus 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 4 okay this is
addition
but it's my own takes forever right so
we have a shortcut for addition which is
multiplication 6 lots of 4 okay so we
said that you can sort of take
multiplication is a short way of writing
addition
when you've got lots of positions thank
you well index notation if you remember
this is just the same thing but to the
next level okay so if I were to multiply
these out before I should've actually
written this instead of four plus four
plus four it's all a time if I have 4
times 4 times 4 times 4 there we go
I write this in a new way again as a
shortcut ok so the way I'll write this
is our 4 with a little 6 up the top okay
so we call this a superscript it's
written just above the rest of them okay
so the way I would read this I'll put
this in another color and maybe you want
to do it as well what is this is 4 to
the power of 6 okay now just introduce a
whole bunch of new things let's slow
down okay for the power 6 so that 6 up
there right which is just an
abbreviation for multiply it by itself 6
times okay we call this that number then
we call it a power right 4 to the power
of 6 we also call it an index that's why
it's called index notation if you want a
really super tikki where you can call it
an exponent
now all of these had their own useful
things about them forest is power is the
most color way to talk about it you'd
say for the power 6 almost I don't think
I've ever had someone saying 4 to the
index of 6 that's that's anyway see
that's where that's how we use that but
e Nexus is useful as well the the plural
of index is the word indices IMD IC e s
so when you've got a whole bunch of them
stringing along we call them indices not
indexes what last thing addition
subtraction multiplication division
where we look at the process we have you
know irn on the end of all of them well
you don't really call it power Shin or
index should you call it exponentiation
okay so in just the same way that
multiplication is a shortcut for
addition exponentiation or powers or
indices right there a shortcut of
multiplication so for the power of 6
another way to say is 4 multiplied by
itself
6 times okay that's what it means
so